[Musique]
et pour en débattre
nous sommes avec isabelle landreau
avocate spécialiste en nouvelles
technologies bonsoir d'être landreau
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france pour en débattre donc yves
buisson épidémiologistes président du
groupe coville 19 de l'académie
nationale de médecine bonsoir à vous il
va buisson merci également d'être avec
nous alors stop qu'ovide on sait que
c'est très décrié y aller pour y aller
contre quelle est votre réaction vous
yves buisson même la réaction c'est que
tous les moyens sont bons pour lutter
contre cette épidémie qui est une
épidémie mortelle très grave et qui
n'est pas terminée donc c'est un moyen
intéressant qui va permettre de détecter
des nouveaux cas et donc je crois qu'il
faut absolument pas s'en priver dans la
mesure bien entendu où ce moyen respecte
les droits des personnes et le crois que
des garanties suffisantes ont été donnés
dans ce sens-là l'académie nationale de
médecine a émis un communiqué pour
souligner l'intérêt réel que cette
mesure peut apporter dans la lutte
contre l'épidémie
mais en soulignant qu' il fallait bien
entendu garantir un certain nombre de
droits un avait donc déjà que ce rsa
repose sur le volontariat et qu'il n'y
ait pas de viol autorisation est que ces
données soient détruites dès que
l'épidémie sera terminée dès qu'elles ne
sont plus nécessaires donc aucune
données nominales une donnée de
permettant la reconnaissance des
personnes également ne doit être stocké
donc dans ces conditions l'académie de
médecine a donné un avis tout à fait
favorables et auquel bien entendu je me
rallie qu'en pense l'avocate isabelle à
landreau bonsoir alors évidemment pour
l'avocate je suis pas du tout d'accord
je pense que cette application est les
accessoires inutiles accessoires
pourquoi parce que nous avons déjà des
fichiers existants nous avons deux
fichez nous avons le fichier si des
quais le système d'information de
dépistage
or nous avons l'ensemble des résultats
des laboratoires du test collet 19 grâce
à ce fichier side
d'autre part nous avons un deuxième
fichier qui est le fichier contact colis
qui est essentiellement pour le domaine
médical et qui permet de suivre
d'accompagner les personnes déjà
infectées
donc il me semble que avec cet arsenal
ona c'est déjà suffisant on n'a pas
besoin d'avoir une application qui va
tracer
bien sûr nous avons des crypto
identifiant qui relie un numéro de
téléphone qui nous relie à une personne
physique mais cette personne va être
tracé et elle va être suivi dans ses
déplacements donc pour moi c'est
accessoire utile
inité pourquoi parce que c'est une
atteinte à notre liberté notre liberté
individuelle la liberté de déplacement
d'aller de venir et je pense que ll sera
prêt limité en effet le succès de cette
application dépend du téléchargement
massif
il faut à peu près que 60% des français
téléchargent cette application pour que
ce soit vraiment efficace et il me
semble que en comparaison des pays
étrangers notamment l'australie où c'est
que 5% de personnes qui ont le
télécharger l'islande où là c'est le
plus gros pourcentage 40%
eh bien nous je pense que le français
moyen va être réticent à télécharger
cette application puisque c'est du
traçage et donc son effet sera limité et
villes sont est ce que vous répondez
donc résumons substance aller parle de
mettre landreau atteinte aux libertés
inutile on va avoir du mal à convaincre
les français qu'ils n'auront pas envie
d'être tracé qu'elle a été vous le
retour sur le terrain justement un des
patients français
je voudrais leur dire que ce n'est pas
se superposent pas aux deux autres
méthodes de détection des patients qui
existent effectivement et les méthodes
de déclaration des tests positifs qui
existe et puis et le traçage autour d'un
cas qui avait que les
les groupes qui sont mis en sont mis en
oeuvre par autour du médecin qui a fait
le diagnostic d'un cas c'est
complémentaire puisque la personne qui
ce qui va déclarer qu'elle est infectée
par le comique 19 n'a pas forcément été
testée et elle peut être malade avoir
été diagnostiquée positive à voir même
un test négatif et être tout à fait
suspecte d'avoir la maladie
si elle déclare on va contacter des
personnes avec qui elle était en
proximité pendant une qu'elle calcule
pendant quelques minutes à moins d'un
mètre et ces personnes elle ne les
connaît pas lorsqu'on fait le traçage à
partir du médecin ont fait le traçage
dans les personnes dans les relations
dans les personnes que l'on connaît on
sait qu'on a été en contact on a peur on
a vu monsieur machin ou madame truc dans
les classes sur les personnes qu'on ne
connaît pas donc c'est un outil
supplémentaire complémentaire par
rapport aux deux autres méthodes de
détection et je crois que dans cette
période de déconfinement il faut se
servir de tout ce qui est à notre portée
bien entendu il faut pas faire n'importe
quoi
les français sont très sont très
paranoïaque en ce qui concerne le
traçage les libertés les big brother on
se raconte beaucoup d'histoires alors
que tout le monde utilise des moyens
d'aider par les réseaux sociaux ne prend
aucune précaution et c'est vrai que les
gens sont tracées ils sont tracées à
leur insu ou pas leur insu psaume où
souvent les gens s'en fichent
complètement mais ils sont tracées et
alors quand il s'agit d'organiser
quelque chose pour la santé pour la
santé publique alors là a alors là on
fait appel aux libertés individuelles et
on se souvient quand les français qu'il
faut se bagarrer pour défendre ses
libertés
c'est complètement à côté de la plaque
je crois qu'il faut se souvenir qu'on a
affaire à une épidémie qui est
extrêmement dangereuse qui a tué
beaucoup de monde et qui n'a pas fini de
tuer et pour laquelle il faut se donner
absolument tous les moyens pour en venir
à bout
isabelle ans dont vous voyez
sourire on a laissé terminer
l'argumentaire du buisson voilà c'est
vrai que beaucoup de français un livre
leur vie sur les réseaux sociaux et
quand il s'agit de la santé publique et
bien on se trouve un petit peu méfiant
qu'est ce que vous répondez oui alors je
trouve qu'on agit sur la crainte de la
résurgence et elle n'est pas là pourquoi
parce que les chiffres récentes
démontrent qu'il n'ya pas cette
résurgence
donc on agit vraiment en prévention et
comme l'a souligné monsieur buisson
l'application va pas démontré que vous
est contaminé c'est une suspicion de
rencontres avec des gens contaminés donc
on va tracer des genres une suspicion de
contamination donc on est vraiment en
amont donc pour moi évidemment c'est
c'est complètement une entrave à la
liberté d'aller et venir et les données
seront stockées cette évidence est un
serveur centralisé qu'elle gérait pas
leur autorité de santé
le parlement européen avait été contre
cette architecture en disant attention
ça peut générer des failles plus que des
serveurs décentralisés
ce n'a pas été suivi donc évidemment il
ya un risque
il ya un risque sur nos libertés
individuelles et puis il ya un risque
aussi sur le fait que ce traçage
bien sûr c'est pour la sécurité
sanitaire et nous via tous les gens
qu'on vient mais est-ce que ça va pas
faire un précédent
est ce que finalement on comptera pas
dans une société de surveillance
elle et les quartiers devant et puis
avec docilement le plus de citoyens
français va s'habituer
parce que finalement on a cette excuse
bien sûr de sauver des vies je pense
qu'on a des outils suffisants qui ont
fait leurs preuves et aussi on a le
maillage des médecins de ville français
donc comptons sur l'existant pourquoi
ajouter une application de plus qui en
plus ont fait le jeu des piranhas ce
qu'on va rémunérer des pirates à hauteur
de 2000 euros pour casser les failles
ainsi de suite donc moi je crains qu'on
rentre dans une société de surveillance
et que docilement le français soit
endormi par set
question parce que évidemment il faut
sauver des vies alors il ya plusieurs
choses à iv sont la société de
surveillance mais il ya quand même
quelque chose d'important qui a été
soulevée sur lequel vous ne semblez pas
d'accord isabelle landreau bon qui n'est
pas médecin bien sûr mais comme personne
ne l'est en tout cas à part vous aux
nîmois en tout cas nous affirme voilà
que c'est peut-être trop tard en fait
que l'épidémie est en train de marquer
clairement le pas exhumant les chiffres
sont tombés 107 morts de plus en france
mardi la baisse qui se poursuit en
réanimation
vous vous pensez qu'on va vraiment en
avoir besoin que ce n'est pas un petit
peu tard tout s'est mis en place
aujourd'hui on s'éteint c'est un très
mauvais argument parce que effectivement
l'épidémie il faut s'en réjouir et sur
la fin elle est sur la fin mais on a
encore deux depuis ces dernières
semaines on a eu 109 foyer ce qu'on
appelle les clusters qui se subliment
disséminés sur le sol français
à partir de ces foyers qui ont été
identifiés par d'autres méthodes bien
entendu on a pu les on a pu les
circonscrire parce qu'ils ont été
repérés très précocement
ça veut dire pourra ça veut dire que le
virus continue de circuler sans doute à
bas bruit mais ils continuent de
circuler il va continuer de circuler
encore sans doute pendant plusieurs
semaines donc dire que cette méthode
défendre la méthode du stop peu vide
c'est prendre argumente pour sauver des
vies bien oui c'est pour sauver des vies
ce n'est pas une excuse
c'est un objectif c'est notre fierté
même de vouloir sauver des vies et même
si on ne sauve qu'une seule vie grâce à
ce système
eh bien il faudra s'en réjouir je crois
qu'avec ce système bien entendu moi je
ne suis pas pour qu'on soit tous ce flic
et horreur de ça je suis français comme
tout le monde et j'aime pas ça mais là
il ya des garanties et je vois pas quel
serait l'intérêt encore une fois pour le
gouvernement ou pour je ne sais qui de
colliger des données qu'ils sont des
données anonymes pour savoir qu'intel a
eu le qu'ovide franchement multi qui ça
peut intéresser
je crois qu'il sait la queue on tombe un
peu dans la paranoïa
d'autre part ce système va va nous
servir parce que s'il fait preuve d'une
certaine efficacité
il y aura d'autres épidémies et s'était
laissé des moyens
berne maintenant donc il faut se doter
bien sûr il ya le port du masque était
complètement inconnue dans nos dans nos
régions occidentales qui maintenant va
sûrement laisser une habitude très utile
lorsqu'on aura une épidémie d'infections
par voie respiratoire et bien le le le
traçage c'est pas un deuxième pas le
vôtre a sagement enfin disons
l'identification par smartphone peut
être un moyen il laissera un outil utile
pour lutter contre les épidémies mais je
crois qu'il faut pas s'en priver faut
s'en féliciter
on a compris le message et buissons le
mot de la fin très rapidement s'il vous
plaît isabelle landreau le professeur
buisson failli lui sont parlés voilà
quel est l'intérêt du gouvernement vous
vous allez certainement répondre
rapidement s'il vous plaît monsieur
buisson proposition a fait la preuve que
justement l'application est inutile
puisque les clusters ont été identifiés
sans cette application donc nous avons
la possibilité d'isoler les cas
contaminés sans cette application dont
en effet la preuve a été faite par
professeur je vous en remercie c'est
l'intérêt du gouvernement à garder les
données parce que il ya des français qui
se pose la question les données mené
données peuvent être gardées bien sûr il
va falloir vérifier que l soit effacée à
la fin de l'épidémie et on a bien sûr la
clean un acte neil lane sea pour assurer
cette mission là mais il se peut aussi
que les français réagissent et demandent
des droits c'est déjà envisagé dans tous
les avis publiés notamment de l'académie
du professeur et aussi de l'académie
scientifique il est envisagé que les
citoyens saisissent et ses autorités et
demandes d'effacement et on a même prévu
une indemnisation
donc il y a quand même des risques merci
merci on n'aura pas eu la réponse sur
l'intérêt du gouvernement mais ça sera
l'objet d'un prochain débat merci en
tout cas tous les deux un
isabelle l'android ville sont d'avoir
accepté de débattre en direct sur notre
antenne